you
hi everyone is cheering this is video 20
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and I'd like to share with you
the Philidor position the Philidor
position is another one of those very
popular rook and pawned end games that
is a must note this is an end game that
is more popular than the Lucena position
the Lucena position is one that I
covered in video 19 in this series if
you've been tracking it closely you'll
recall just as a refresher this is the
Lucena position the stronger sides King
is the one who stands in front of the
pawn I went on to illustrate a universal
method to winning this position type I
showed how to win as the stronger side
compare this with now the Philidor
position or what is just about a move
away or an idea away from being the fill
door position in the Philidor position
it is now the weaker sides King who
stands in front of the pawn this
difference matters what we are trying to
do now as the weaker side is hold this
position to a draw
plenty of games can result in this type
of an end game where you are
unfortunately down upon we want to see a
way to hold this to a draw what is a
very simple and effective method to
drawing this position it is white to
move what to do before I share this
simple and effective method to drawing
let me highlight a couple tempting yet
faulty tries by white so that we can
better understand why the simple and
effective approach to drawing is so good
suppose white inserts a check from
behind right now King d3 he gets to hide
behind the pawn there are no ensuing
file checks and black
as this idea of rook h1 trading rooks
and winning the King and pawn endgame as
an example suppose white makes a passing
move black can give a check white must
block the rooks are exchanged King c2
and there will be no stopping blacks
next three moves black goes on to win
suppose white plays rook to e1 stopping
rook h1 while black can play the rook
over to the other side and all of a
sudden threatened Magan 1 how to stop
this the king must try to flee King c1
rook a 1 white just dropped the rook and
the game what more to try from this
position maybe the white King runs King
c1 black gives a check and flushes the
King away from being in front of the
pawn in fact we are now observing a role
reversal what do I mean by this well it
is now the stronger sides king who
stands in front of the pawn it is now
the Lucena position that we are staring
at black will now go on to win rook
check at this moment here no good one
other tempting move maybe to pin the
pawn to the king this is not working
either King III rook a3 the pawn can
block mate is already threatened king c1
rook h1 and similarly what we are
noticing here is that the black king is
able to get out in front of the pawn and
this will allow black to go on to win
rook a to the pawn continues to push we
can give a check King d4 we get the king
out of the pin and we will be promoting
next in both of these tries giving a
check or pinning the pawn to the king
and neither addresses the following and
neither prevents the
King the stronger sides King from
getting out in front of the pawn you may
recall from video eight in this series
the video titled how to promote upon one
of the terms that I used in that video
was that when it's a King and pawn
versus King the King likes to play a
leadership role he likes to be the
leader he likes to be out in front of
the pawn
well black likes to establish that same
thing in these position types as well
when there's also a rook involved he
likes to play a leader role he wants to
be out in front of the pawn well we just
saw that being able to be out in front
of the pawn is good you may eventually
arrive at the Lucena position where the
stronger side will go on to win if this
is something the stronger side wants to
have their king out in front of the pawn
what do you think a good drawing method
would be for white it would be to
prevent the stronger sides came from
getting in front of the pawn so the
drawing method the simple and effective
drawing method here is rook to a3 what
are we doing we are cutting the King off
we're not allowing the stronger sides
King to be in front of the pawn we just
observed how that can get us in some
trouble we'll go on to lose if the King
is able to get out in front of that pawn
now what is this doing exactly well what
can black do at this point he can give a
check but we'll just step up he can give
another check we just step back this is
not progress by black what other try is
there rook G to black has just made a
waiting move we can make a waiting move
as well staying on the same rank we want
to stay in a position where we cut the
King off rook b3 another black could
give another check we would just repeat
we go up as soon as black pushes the
pawn this is now where we reposition our
rook we move the rook
all the way back and get in a position
to give checks to the black king you'll
notice something as soon as this pawn
moves d3 in this case the square d3 is
no longer a safe haven for the black
King in the first faulty attempt that I
shared with you once this check was
given the king was able to play to d3
and be shielded by the pawn there are
now no file checks however in this
position here as soon as the pawn moves
to d3 the square d3 is no longer a safe
haven for the stronger sides King we
play our rook all the way back and now
we are prepared to give checks to black
black and give a check we simply step up
that's the only legal move in this case
another check we simply stay back on the
same files the pawn no problem
King III threatening mate and one well
it's our move now we start giving checks
and there is not a good way to stop them
we just keep giving checks if the King
goes too far away from the pond we can
get right behind and soon enough we will
be hunting down the pond so this is the
key idea we want to cut the King off now
this method here applies to a pond that
is a few moves away even if I were to
shift this upper rank even if it's
Formosa right four moves away the same
method can be applied same idea here is
to cut off the King what's the move here
as white rook to a4 we're stopping the
King from playing that leader role we're
stopping the King from getting out in
front of the pond this method can be
applied to any file pawn I'd like to
also highlight an additional defensive
resource that applies to Knight ponds
and
rook pawns okay so the a B G and H pawns
here is an additional method to drawing
this endgame okay this is again specific
to rook pawns and night pawns defending
sides King is in front of the pawn we
can play down to c1 to the promotion
rank and this will be good enough to
hold as a draw as well I would recommend
that you still implement this idea to
cut off the King right away but with
regard to Knight pawns and rook pawns
this is an additional defense to play to
that promotion rank and there will be
not there won't be a good way to disrupt
the King position we can give a black
and give a couple checks but this is not
any progress there is no getting to the
h1 square in this case black could try
something like this but they will
actually go on to lose rook check drop
the rook in the game so Knight pawns and
rip pawns there is this first rank
defense or promotion rank defense to see
why this is not working for the bishop
pawns the C pawns the C pawn F pawn or
the center pawns the D me pawns let's
see why this first rank defense is not
good rook c1 in this case now if we just
stay on this first rank what's going to
happen is that there's rook h1
threatening rook h1 king g1 can now be
met with f2 check in our King is forced
away from defending that corner square
Knight pawn was not able to force our
King away from the corner Square rook h1
we dropped the rook in the game so again
this cutting off idea is one that we can
apply to all file pawns and there is
also an additional drawing method
involved with the knight pawns in the
rook pawns and that is a first rank
defense or
we can play to this promotion rank and
simply stay there with our rook and we
will be able to hold that to a drum one
last thing that I think you may find
interesting is as follows here is
another position where it is white to
move and basically as a little bit of a
close to this video here is a pop quiz
what would you do as white in this
position if you'd like to go ahead pause
the video see what we you would do as
white okay it may appear that white is
in some serious trouble here there is
only one move that I can make that is
good white can hold this position to a
draw with the following move rook to e2
this is a nice little drawing resource I
can recall this idea being implemented
in the US Chess Championship 2013
between Alejandro Ramirez playing as
white wasn't this exact position but
this idea was implemented in that game
it was a playoff game between Alejandro
Ramirez and gada Kamsky there is this
stalemate resource rook check pawn takes
stalemate if black doesn't take
the rook well now the rook gets to go in
a position to give checks from behind
and the game will result in a drop
basically establishing now
well basically having a Philidor
position on board so this is a little
stalemate trick that may spring about if
the conditions are right the Kings being
opposite from one another and the white
rook on the second or seventh rank there
is this checking idea this is an only
move this is the only move that will
save this position because checkmate is
right around the corner or this idea of
flushing the King away and then being
able to push the pawn through so a nice
little checkmate resource to be aware of
in this in this case Kings opposite from
one another rookie to old results in a
drop so again this is the big idea just
to cut off the king and stay there until
the pawn moves as soon as the pawn moves
you get the rook in a position to give
checks from behind and you will have no
problem holding these position types to
a drum so as usual I hope you got
something out of this video feel free to
leave any feedback in the comment
section below and I'll catch you in the
next one that's all for now take care
bye
you